chérie on va passer au quart d'heure
sans filtre et là c'est ce qui a agité
toute la toile ce week-end est agité
toute la télé yann moix actes il dérapé
c'est la grosse polémique télé du week
end
tout le monde en a parlé c'est
évidemment les propos de yann moix
concernant la police était dans les
terriens du samedi thirard 10 ont
organisé un débat sur la terreur entre
les policiers et les délinquants et yann
moix à une petite phrase qui a rythmé le
week-end de tout le monde
on vous a fait un petit récap regardez
bien et juste après jour également la
réponse de yann moix et on aura deux
personnes avec nos plateaux on aura
l'adjoint au maire de la mairie de
saint-denis et on aura un syndicat de
police qui sera avec nous loïc travers
qui est secrétaire national adjoint
alors secrétaire national adjoint
d'alliance regarde ce week-end
l'écrivain polémiste et chroniqueur de
chez thierry ardisson yann moix est
intervenu sur ces 8 face à deux
policiers et il n'a pas hésité à
critiquer violemment leurs fonctions
si vous venez vérifier que les policiers
ont peur avec caen avec la faiblesse
attise la haine et vous savez très bien
que dire que vous chez dans votre froc
alors que vous faites un métier qui
devrait prendre en compte cette peur la
police française est une des plus
violentes d'europe
la peur au ventre vous n'avez pas les
couilles d'aller dans les endroits
dangereux
des propos immédiatement condamné en
plateau par les invités donc je ne suis
pas dans mon froc plus je vais au boulot
je suis fier du travail suggère des
fonctionnaires de police
on chipote rock je pense que je vais
vous inscrire en faux c'est scandaleux
ce que vous dites
alors selon vous yann moix at il dérapé
alors yann moix at il dérapé
honda a vu la ccog alors c'est
incroyable c'est la première fois que
variés et yann moix at il dérapé
oui il ya toute la bande de grecs qui
vont faire la famille en dehors c'est
incroyable et de l'autre côté il va
essayer de se défendre tout seul c'est
ben ali bagayoko
merci d'être avec nous bali bagayoko il
est l'adjoint au maire de la mairie de
saint denis vous êtes extrêmement
élégant vous êtes seul
c'est pas que les jo ne vous aime pas
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec
vous mais merci d'être là et vous êtes
plutôt d'accord fait partie de la france
a soumises et vous êtes plutôt d'accord
avec yann moix on a également avec nous
loïc travers lui de travers merci d'être
avec nous je traîne rue vous avoir parce
que je voulais absolument que vous soyez
là ce soir vous êtes secrétaire national
adjoint d'alliance vous êtes très en
colère après les propos de yann moix que
sur la police sur facebook allianz a
même partagé le lien du csa pour
signaler la séquence
loïc juste vous vous trouvez qu'il a
dérapé dites nous pourquoi
pour nous il a dérapé c'est évident
sont des propos gratuits méprisant digne
d'un imbécile qui ne connaît pas le
sujet qui l'a qu'il a abordés il est
dans la droite ligne de tous ceux qui
font en sorte de diaboliser en fait la
police de faire en sorte que et bien on
vend de ce produit anti flics comme ça
peut être le cas avec mathieu kassovitz
qui a traité nos collègues de bâtard
après être revenu sur ses propos et
après avoir dit en fait c'est pas vrai
je connaissais pas de quoi je parlais
parce que c'est ça donne une version
commerciale mercantile on à la semaine
dernière une une société d'assurance qui
a fait une publicité sur le fait que
tous les policiers matraques les jeunes
on avait déjà eu le cas avec une affiche
de la cgt voyez donc on a plusieurs
depuis sept huit mois c'est cette
banalisation systématique anti flics et
qui est particulièrement gênante pour
mes collègues qui sont aussi des pères
de familles qui ont des enfants et qui
rentre avec ce fardeau à la maison alors
on va revenir tout sur tout ça yann moix
et on va revenir sur la sphère minute
par minute ce que le 7 février 2018 yann
moix est invité chez nous pour parler de
son documentaire sur les migrants à
calais est déjà à l'époque au moment
d'évoquer la police il y va un petit peu
regarde il ya des exactions qui sont
cachés par une pourcentage de policiers
qui s'en donnent à coeur joie
car lorsque les exilés arrive à menton
on n'utilise pas des extincteurs de
lacrymogènes mais à calais c'est la fête
à neuneu toute la journée au caire alors
donc vous est ce que vous êtes vous en
voulez vraiment sur ce sujet la surca
vraiment à calais parce que vous dites
que dans dans les deux dossiers au
dessus voilà sur dans d'autres villes ça
se passe pas comme ça dans ce film je
donne la parole aux calaisiens qui les
initiations très compliqué je reviendrai
peut-être rapidement et pourquoi je n'ai
pas pu filmer comme je souhaitais les
forces de l'ordre parce que malgré
toutes les démarches que j'ai faites
auprès de mr l'intérieur on ne m'a
jamais répondu
j'ai tout essayé j'ai des amis crs je me
demandais ce que je peut embarquer avec
vous il faut demander à la hiérarchie et
la hiérarchie m'a toujours dit non alors
voyez déjà yann moix que c'était donc
sur ce plateau
c'est vrai que son documentaire recalés
et était diffusée sur arte et dans ce
documentaire on y voit des passages très
fort avec la police impliqués sous
faites vous tout ça en fait vous en
fichez toile
dans un passage de son documentaire on y
voit des migrants être sauvagement
agressés par les forces de l'ordre
je vous préviens ces images sont
difficiles et ses sacs à vous lire iad
manger sa réponse il ya deux mois on va
revenir là dessus dans un stand nécrose
des tissus respiratoires et digestifs
oedème pulmonaire hémorragie des glandes
surrénales sont les principaux dommages
causés par le chloro à s'étoffer nonne
ou gaz lacrymogènes la wii ignore alors
qu'il fera la une de libération
symbolisant des violences que malgré ces
images
le président de la république continue
de réfuter
alors ça c'était donc son documentaire
sur arte samedi à 19h51 sur ces 8 c'est
le moment qui crée la polémique tir
ardisson recevait frédéric ploquin
autour d'un livre sur la peur qui aurait
changé de camp entre la police et les
délinquants et au moment de demander
l'avis de yann moix yann la joue franc
jeu et là c'est là c'est ça c'est pour
ça que vous êtes là on est dire ici que
les policiers ont peur même si avec la
faiblesse attise la haine et vous savez
très bien que dire que vous chez dans
votre froc
alors que vous faites un métier qui
devrait prendre en compte cette peur la
peur est humaine et ça je ne reproche
pas la peur vous devriez l'intégrer la
police française est une des plus
violentes d'europe vos cibles préférées
ce sont les pauvres et les milieux
défavorisés et je suis moi même comme
tous les français le plus souvent
spectateur du harcèlement vous pratiquez
sur des gens inoffensif
parce que effectivement la peur au
ventre vous n'avez pas les couilles
d'aller dans les endroits dangereux
alors loïc ça est ce que ça vous a
blessé
c'est particulièrement violent c'est
particulièrement gratuit justice tout à
l'heure et effectivement c'est blessant
pour les policiers et je ne mettrai pas
à son à son à son niveau
parce que la première chose qui m'est
venue c'est un flot d'insultés comme
beaucoup de mes collègues d'ailleurs que
je ne prononcerai pas ce soir parce que
justement c'est pas comme ça qu'on doit
s'exprimer et ça représente pas du tout
les policiers en général alors et noir
même si vous trouvez que yann moix a
dérapé je vois un petit peu fait
dodeline oui pourquoi
mais non mais parce que je sais pas
yann moix que c'est tout à fait légitime
pour parler de sa poche et il a fait il
est allé à calais c'est très bien mais
pas complètement convaincu que ce soit
quelqu'un voilà qui qu'ils soient dans
le ghetto un bien fou autant que nous
d'ailleurs mais en revanche c'est vrai
qu'on peut pas ignorer qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup beaucoup de dérapages
moi j'habite dans le 19e arrondissement
et je vois souvent quand même la police
moi je respecte beaucoup la police où
vous faites un travail formidable
vraiment et c'est pas vrai qu'en france
c'est la plus violente et c'est en
revanche dans le 19ème je constate de ce
que je vois beaucoup de l'arrestation un
peu curieuse toujours les mêmes
personnes autour des petits larcins et
c'est monsieur parce que voilà je jouis
dans des conditions sans vie d'un homme
et dans un quartier plutôt compliqué et
j'assiste à des vrais dérapage de
manière quotidienne monsieur c'est ça ne
veut pas dire que la police dans son
entièreté l'express anxieux c'est ce que
veut dire yann moix yade il ya des vrais
les vraies difficultés à travailler dans
certains quartiers c'est clair il faut
pas il faut pas le nid ce sont des gens
qu'on a des exemples qui démontrent
complètement la force de ce que dit yann
moix en l'occurrence nos collègues de
viry châtillon qui ont été cramé dans
une bagnole dont certains n'ont toujours
pas repris le travail aujourd'hui ça
c'était d'une violence absolument
incroyable on a le couple de policiers
qui a été agressée en 77 à otis sur leur
temps personnel c'est à dire ils
n'avaient pas leurs tenues
juste parce qu'ils ont été reconnus et
certainement parce que eux ont eu
pardonnez moi d'être vulgaire les
couilles d'aller dans la cité sur le 93
où ils sont et où travaillent tous les
jours et c'est parce qu'ils les
dérangeait qu'ils sont venus se faire
justice chez une nounou sachs donc ça je
crois que rien que ça à quand la bonne
arrivée au marley alors monsieur mamadou
bagayoko qu'avec d'où vous êtes
l'adjoint au maire de la mairie de saint
denis vous êtes plutôt d'accord avec
yann moix qu'est ce que vous avez à dire
à ce que vient revient sur la question
la tonalité bien sûr qu'on a il a
utilisé les mots qui sont inappropriées
soit une fois qu'on a dit ça
dans ce qu'il évoque et on ce que l'on
me voit est ce que il ya vérité ou pas
parce que quand on voit la personne se
faire frapper jusqu'à preuve du
contraire c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
ça s'apprend un chose la deuxième chose
que des officiers de police
et bien sûr été outré on peut le
comprendre mais la question de fond qui
est posée c'est de dire moi j'ai grandi
en quartier j'ai fait toute ma vie dans
ces quartiers givi encore d'accord et
madame a eu l'occasion de l'évoquer il
ya des phénomènes qui sont pas
tolérables et le fait qu'à amener on
puisse dire que ce n'est pas tolérable
pour un service public
de tranquillité publique si la même
chose que l'on est capable de dire quand
un agent de propreté fait pas son
travail quand un policier dérape on doit
être en capacité les impôts ici et ça
c'est important de le dire parce que si
jamais on commence à se dire au nom du
fait que c'est un service public qui est
travail dans les conditions difficiles
nous ne peut pas avoir un avis dessus
alors là on a un vrai problème et c'est
bien le problème qui est posé
cirque il faut qu'on soit capable quand
il ya un monde d'énergie à des dérapages
au pouvoir le dire ça c'est assez clair
gilles verdez là mais monsieur je vous
écoute parler avec attention votre
langage extrêmement châtié vous
n'insultez pas ce qui est intolérable
c'est la manière de parler là on n'est
pas sur le fond non mais moi je vais
vous dire si j'étais la semaine j'aurai
coupé ça parce que c'est pour moi une
incitation à la haine contre les
policiers voient l'avancé votre avion
n'aurait pas tout alors il n'est pas
coupée du tout alors je vous le dis mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
syndicats de police qui ont tué public
et un communiqué notamment le syndicat
alternatif police voilà chaque jour des
hommes et des femmes travaillent au
péril de leur vie par ses propos il ya
deux mois me salit la mémoire de toutes
celles des sous ceux qui sont morts
puisqu'il est pour qu'ils puissent
dormir en paix alternatif policiers
d'été à d'ores et déjà saisi le csa pour
ses déclarations à vomir qui n'incite
pas les plus jeunes à une heure de
grande écoute à respecter les policiers
alternative police est attaché à la
liberté d'expression droit fondamental
de notre pays mais cela n'autorise pas
de tenir n'importe quel propos au top
unity il est revenue il est ensuite
revenu dessus sur france info il n'y va
pas de main morte
regardez ils feraient bien de venir
mettre son nez dans le caca que l'on a
tous les jours pour parler crûment et
pour être à la hauteur de son
vocabulaire particulièrement vulgaire et
charpié ils feraient bien de venir avec
nous donc sur le terrain voir un peu
comment ça se passe prendre quelques
pavés dans la figure en restant poli et
puis on verra comme ils disent il a des
couilles comme les policiers d'y aller
tous les jours et j'espère que monsieur
moi que ce soit très content que des
policiers ne suis pas dans leur froc
quand il sera confronté à un tel
problème et qui sera content de voir la
police débarque à son domicile
ça donc c'était c'était là la réaction
de monsieur jacob et à 19h11
yann moix a réagi pour la première fois
sur europe 1 il est resté sur ses
positions
regardez la grossièreté et l'indécence
de gérard collomb je ne les ai jamais
vus dans ses paroles c'est un homme au
langage policé je les ai vus dans les
coups de matraque qu'ils prodiguent aux
migrants à calais à longueur de journée
quand quatre cinq six sept huit
policiers sont parfois sur un enfant de
16 ans et le la mine de coûts et le gaz
j'ai rien d'autre à rajouter je vous dit
tout et je vous lis est là et il a aidé
je voulais essayer de de revenir sur
pattes pas de revenir sur ses propos
mais il veut il me dit qu il vous salue
il dit et il dit lui que la peur est
humaine je sais que les policiers sont
souvent abandonnés par les politiques
c'est ce qu'il a voulu dire
yann moix et que beaucoup sont courageux
voilà ce que nous dit yann moix vous
fait calmez vous je vous donne sa
réponse elle encore alors beaucoup sont
courageux la police travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles et précaires ont
leur alloue peu d'argent cmox kim et
kris 1 en outre ils sont pris dans une
politique du chiffre
intenable et sont durement sanctionnés
en cas de riposte qui tourne mal sous
effectifs locaux vétustes ordre confus
le logiques contradictoires tout cela je
le sais tout le monde le sait c'est
l'évidence mais dont il dit ça alors ça
n'a rien à voir et à l'importance dans
la première affaire à finir de calaire
janvier 2018 aucun policier n'a été jugé
aucune enquête fin juillet rien et en
plus il est revenu sur ses propos
eh bien là c'est la deuxième fois qu'il
revient sur ses prothèses mais sans les
nier
il s'explique défaire alors il commence
la dilution toute simple que j'aimerais
lui donner je vais vous le voyez je suis
vous dirigez la sphère benalla depuis la
ferme et dallas et un statut
d'observateur qui a été créée le 17
septembre
je vous remets cette possibilité donnée
voici que l'invite
il pourra juger merci objectivement de
ce que l on a de la montée c'est bon
j'ai tous les peuples 1 seconde
alors non halal et il me dit aussi je
vous lis qui me dit il dit tout cela je
le sais tout le monde le sait c'est
l'évidence mais dit lui aussi que je
suis en colère car dans les
manifestations et face aux micros les
mêmes policiers n'ont tellement plus
peur de personne qu'il frappe durement
qu'ils frappent criminellement il y a
deux poids et deux mesures en banlieue
où ce 40 en banlieue on se carapate à
calais ou dans les manifs on se défoule
on dégaine la matraque en gaz des
mineurs sans parler des contrôles au
faciès qui sont devenus une habitude et
sont une honte que les policiers heures
très bien cela ne doit pas leur faire
oublier toutes leurs interventions
disproportionnées et gratuite
voilà l'honnêteté cher cyril est selon
moi de dire aussi ce dont est capable la
police face aux faibles je ne crois
enfin pas que sa place
voilà ce sur les plateaux de télévision
à pleurer sur la détériore la
crédibilité encore importante malgré
tout qui lui restent sûrs respecte ceux
qui prennent des risques pas ce qu'ils
se défoulent sur des innocents offense
inoffensive voilà voilà la réponse des
danois qui les complète voilà qui
complète elle est complète alors c'est
vrai que quand on est dans l'interface
que tarbes et non mais les complète
parce que quand tu as un moment donné il
est connu crête non c'est un vent de
l'est il a eu le lien par exemple avec
qui viennent entre nîmes et voir dans
quelle merde on est il le dit à mon nez
dans le premier passage
d'accord c'est à dire qu'il qualifie en
fin de compte ces quartiers de merde
c'est ça qui dit on pourrait globalisé
aussi on pourrait passer un temps sur ça
en disant si c'est un scandale
oui mais quand il qualifie en fin de
compte six quartiers de merde il dit les
difficultés que rencontrent cet officier
a travaillé dans l'équation que ce n'est
pas évidente mais voilà ce prix met donc
dit d'accord j'ai été choqué par
énormément de vent de ça j'étais choquée
par exemple je vis dans un quartier
je vis dans une vie cent dix mille
habitants que l'on puisse qualifier mon
quartier pardon de merde je dis non
yann moix mine de rien et ça n'empêche
en rien qu'à un moment donné on puisse
amener distinguer ceux qui faute et je
désespère qu' on est tous d'accord pour
le monsieur qui n'ira pas tant est que
ce qui dérape
ce qui dérange doit être fait pour le
sauver
non monsieur monsieur beaulieu moi je
voulais vous dire un truc mine de rien
on vous dit ça ce qui les ratent dans
tous les métiers il ya déjà 10 m synchro
de sanctionner dans tous les métiers on
est championnes et après quand on dérape
alors moi je voudrais dire mine de rien
les propos de yann moix là qu'il a écrit
je trouve kg il revient peu à peu à la
première fois il revient sur les
premiers expliqué voilà l'idée de relier
mais si effectivement ce métier s'il
l'avait expliqué comme ça dès la
première fois je serai pas là ce soir
ah ouais ouais mais ça dans ma mission
n'aura pas fait le buzz c'est sympa et
moi je suis là je voudrais juste
rajouter on le voyait à l'éducation et
propose n'est pas dégoûté des coups
portés et de nos collègues qui sont les
plus sûres sur le sont parfois mises en
cause
il ya des conseils de discipline toutes
les semaines à la préfecture de police
le contrôle que tu fasses un policier en
france c'est parmi les plus les on est
le pays parmi les poules et les
contrôles sont le plus important au
monde a certainement avec ce seul le
contrôle pénale bien évidemment la
justice l'igpn
je veux dire sérieusement le pen quand
des collègues effectivement sont
suspectés d'être intervenus d'une façon
particulière dans une dent dans une
situation et qu'on retrouvait bien
l'absence de prime à la fin du mois ah
oui le fait qu'il soit largement plus
que dans d'autres prophètes je soutiens
ce sujet par rapport aux propos très
vite mais ça tu sais je suis pas l'aval
tracts jean-michel également un jeu
c'est le fait qu'ils disent que les
policiers n'ont pas de couilles d'aller
dans certains les immenses et lucien pas
non plus de rester ils se font tabasser
callas avons eu autant elle a plusieurs
qui sont blessés et là chaque semaine
les policiers qu'ils se suicident à
cause des conditions de travail puis
qu'ils ont peut pas dire qu'ils n'ont
pas de couilles au cul je veux pas
défendre yann moix mais a subi c'est
vrai que minot ce qu'il a écrit je
trouve que là il est beaucoup me durable
c'est une autre analyse elle est dans la
suite les chiffres soient tous faire des
erreurs dans une émission mais à chaque
guerrier en fait on revient on a
rivalisé une situation la violence
policière il en a fait une généralité je
crois que mois passé souffre du syndrome
de la praye l'après on n'est pas couché
il a déjà de faire sensation
médiatiquement pour exister un poisson
analyse vous savez pas d'accord avec
vous mais c'est sympa de vous entendre
on verra pour le clip c'est sympa c'est
vrai que nous on a des policiers je vous
dis je voudrais par exemple j'ai regardé
la soirée de l'info sur ces huit là dans
la faune avait une scène assez dur voilà
avec des policiers ea qui ont dû un peu
de mal à lutter et c'est vrai que quand
on voit ça on se dit minois les
policiers ont du courage
les hommes de franck vont tenter de
prendre l'ascendant face aux quatre
policiers
hélas à gauche de l'écran
c'est une policière qui est tout proche
de se faire écraser par une caravane
les esprits s'échauffent mais franck
reprend la main des véhicules rentrent à
nouveau pour le moment leur plan
fonctionne comme prévu
les policiers bat même en retraite voilà
alors après ça c'est un exemple et c'est
vrai qu'il ya aussi des cas oui je
voulais même pas ce que je voulais dire
c'est que quand même allez un petit peu
sur instagram tous les jours on trouve
des préaux ou là bas c'est vrai où la
police malgré des contextes de banaliser
parce qu'il faut pas banaliser y compris
les faits de cette nature là siens
la deuxième chose c'est que qu'est ce
qu'on voit là on voit quoi dans l'action
on voit en fin de compte qu'en fait les
équipes de policiers sont aussi sont
dans une situation où en fin de compte
ils n'ont pas le nombre ces sacs sont
pas les responsables
loïc et la soirée vous avez vous en
résumé je voudrais conclure sur cette
affaire qu'est ce que vous avez à dire à
yann moix que ce soit je sais que vous
voulez absolument débattre avec yann
moix a pas du tout a été à la hauteur de
ce qu'il peut être là il s'est
transformé en pantins télévisuel où il a
fait du du vraiment de deux lentilles
police primaires ce que ce qu'on déteste
tous les jours parce que quand on vit
avec ses tripes son métier de policier
on trouve particulièrement injuste et
bien cette cette analyse d'ailleurs qui
n'en est pas une
mais ces propos qui qui qui en fait ont
simplement dénigrer des policiers leur
famille et tous ceux qui oeuvrent tous
les jours parce que c'est le dernier
rempart de la république
merci s'il vous plaît vous attendez des
sanctions du csa on a demandé et
facilement au ministre de l'intérieur
est bien de déposer plainte
ce qu'il n'a pas fait d'ailleurs dans la
première fois d'ailleurs c'est comme un
enfant pour être tué mais j'avoue le
sanctionnait pas il recommence mais
c'est exactement ce qu'il a fait et yann
moix saisie par navx saisir si nos
collègues on les a on leur a fait écrire
c'est ça pour qu'ils puissent
massivement démontré leur mécontentent
alors moi je déteste quand on dénonce
aussi ça m'est cher